well the budget is essentially a
collection of lots of different economic
judgments put together based on all of
the statistics on the state of how the
economy is doing and behind me here you
can see this console of how the economy
is doing various different parts of it
it looks complicated but we're going to
take you through some of the most
important bits and really the most
important number of all one that the
Chancellor will I'm sure make a lot of
is the question of just how fast the
economy is growing GDP now this is the
best measure of economic growth and the
big number to look out for is this one
2014 two point four percent is the
growth rate that the Office of Budget
Responsibility was previously talking
about that's likely to get upgraded
maybe by quite a bit and the upshot of
that the other question of course is
working out what happens after that and
maybe that weaker-than-expected but the
big upshot of that is that maybe a
little bit of money to spend so the
question is let's just look at some of
the possible policy decisions we'll be
talking about over the course of the
next 24 hours and clearly childcare
we've already talked about that a little
bit savings there may well be something
for savers they have had a tough time
recently with very low interest rates if
you'll do see another freeze on fuel
duty expected from the Chancellor be
freezing that for a long time now help
to mom heard about that being extended
what happens to alcohol taxes and
tobacco's sin taxes as they're so known
but most of all I think focus is going
to be on tax allowances in other words
how much do you get tax-free before you
start having to pay tax and also more
importantly who is now facing the
highest levels of taxation the olden
days used to talk about the 40 P rate of
tax being something for their wealthiest
families nowadays an increasing number
of people are facing I'm going to show
you though the white bars here showed
you how many people paid each level of
tax in 2010 and the red bar is how many
pay it at the moment you can see just
look at this higher rate of tax in
particular you can see back in 2010 you
had three million people paying that you
can see it just there in 2014 right now
is 4.4 million people paying that a rise
of 1.4 million people that's why there's
gonna be so much
focus on those tax rates